im letzten Juni ist es ub-oot mit 5
Personen an Bord auf dem weag zu der
Titanic im Nordatlantik verloren
gegangen kurz vorher ist vor der
griechische Küste als flüchtlingsbot
gesunken mit hunderte von Todesopfer was
hätte euch mehr interessiert viele hab
komplett gefunden dass die rie Touristen
mehr Aufmerksamkeit bekommen als
Flüchtling wo vertrunken sind verteilen
wires Mitgefühl nicht wahnsinnig
[Musik]
unkracht hi heute danke ich mit euch
nach über Empathie und über ih dunkle
sie z.B über sogenannte halfers Syndrom
aber zerst noch mal zurück zum ubot auf
der re zu der Titanic und dem
flüchtlingstdrama natürlich ist immer
schlimm wenn Mens ums le aber im Fall
vom ubot sind F freiwillig auf eine
wagige Expedition im anderen Fall sind
bis zu 700 Flüchtling vertrunk drunter
Kind und Babys msche wo Land Verl will
sie ihre Familie ihr Heimat nicht
bringen od Arbeit oder politisch
verfolgt werdet warum fber mit im erste
Fall und nicht im zweit grü aus der
Psychologie erstens F
viter wenn vorstellen K dass wir selber
betroffen wäre oder Verwanden oder
frunde nicht alle so krass Hobb
Expedition klar aberensw von de Tourist
ist Realität doch n als die V der
Flüchtling W in Mar stieget zweitens sch
mit dem ubot mal neues es K nicht
verloren auf W zu der Titanik trag im
Mittelmeer gehört tragisch wi fast sch
dazu man gewt sich wahnsinnig schnell
schlimme Nachrichten stumpft ab
Selbstschutz drittens sind im ein Fall
vi bedroht im andere wenig irgendwenn
sind sogar nam V all UB bekanntie mit
Bild konkret genüber umso besser kan
sich füh das heißt Empathie sich lag und
Gefühlswelt von den andere Personen
könen in versetzen aber wie genau
funktioniert das eigentlich mit Empathie
sch philosophe David und Adam Smith
beide 18 Jahrhundert hab sich genau die
Frage gestellt möglich macht Empathie
Vorstellungskraft z.B tut mega Leid wo
im sbedensraurant stolpert und volle
Tablet K so gut vorstellen wie sich
dasfühlt wenn alle so Glotze und all am
B Lied dass man richtig mitliedet
vielleicht spüren wir sogar der Schmerz
wenn sich der bachvogel noch knblutig
Schatt der David J schriebt die Menschen
verhalten sich in ihrem Innern
zueinander wie Spiegel viele J nach dem
J h man in der vorschicht
Spiegelneuronen entdeckt und im jum s
die thesee Ken bestätigen wenn man z.B
gesh dass geschlagen wird sind die gich
Regionen im Hirn aktiv wie wenn man
selber geschlagen wird der David und der
Adam Smith hab mit Schrift natürlich
auch Thomas hobs geschossen wit der
Mensch sie Mensch ein Wolf und mir alle
in er Linie Egomane sie sag g mir msche
sind in erster Linie mitfühlen die
wesseo am Schicksal V anderen
natürlicher wies Teil
Empathie einfachit grundlag für
moralische Motivation nur wen fü und
mitfü sind bereit und Rücksicht rein
rationale gründ lang nicht damit
Verhalten abpasset aber wenn es nicht
Vernunft gründ zum Handel motiviert
sondern tempathie haben wir denn nicht
das Problem doch sagt einige z.p der FR
Brei die im Burch die dunklen Seiten der
Empathie
l gründ warum tempempathie auch dunkle
ste h erstens gilt die sogenannte
Arithmetik von Mitleid je weniger
Personen liedet umso besser können wir
mitfühlen und umso enner sind wir bereit
zuen mit Gruppe oder ganz bevölker hab
viel weniger Mitleid als mit einer
Person W schlimms passiert hilsw setz
darum gern auf parterschafte die Spende
unterstütz denn es ganz konkret Kind und
sind spendabler als wenn es darum g die
Struktur zu veränderen wo viel g
zweitens hilftempathie leider zum Kön
besonders grausam sie od wo andere
MT geradeum so pass genau setz will er
weiß was am meiste weh tut
ke Garantie zumonders nzi drittens
Empathie politische Konflikt verstärk
empathisch s meistens nur mit den woug
sch auf der richtige s ST mitfühlum wie
Variante V sogenannte confirmation bias
ein bestätigungsfehler wirk wir hab
Mitgefühl mit den wo man super findet
was Partein zuszlich verstärkt wenn so
den hindert fühl sogar n auf politische
Konflikt l und für beide s Verständnis
zeigigen was für Lösig von de Problem
dringend nötig wär anstell von me
Mitgefühl und Empathie müss wir dum
viicht wieder meh Vernunft und
nchternhheit forderen statt Empathie
krechtigkeit und es geht wi Problem mit
Empathie wenn wiruren des Lied V anderen
in versetz denn könen wir auch am Eland
zerbreche für Simon ist z
andere
immer sie zu sich mit Hut und H
Widerstand g unter drrückig Hunger und
Krieg verschrieben zimon de B wo gichtig
wie Simon in Paris studiert hat hat für
der extrematz wenig Verständnis das weiß
Notiz memoire Simon B beschriebt wie
Simon Nachricht von große Hungersnot in
China in bitter
trenbricht B fasziniert aber später nur
noch befremdet fürimon got W die
Philosophie drum andere Mens glücklicher
zu machen aufgab ist für sie viel
mehr Existenz ein sin finden Simon we
hat offenbar nur trochig bemerk gemacht
wo sie sich
kennengelerntht dass sie Hunger Simon
vollkommenab im Kampf für Welt mit Kräft
gestorben hat ih Mitstudentin um viel
Jahr überlebt allerdings hat sie es
leang selbst zwiel und ist recht
unglücklich um sich selber und ih
liebesbezieh kreist zum andere und der
Blick Welt hat ihreicht sogar gut da im
Rückblick schriebt sie über Simon we sie
hab sie benedet um das Herz wo im Stand
für der ganz Erdkreis sch wer zu
empathisch ist überltisch das gilt vor
allem denn wenn man nicht nursam sind
sondern immer auch gerade W hfe und
nftchte denn R vom halfers Syndrom
halfers Syndrom ist für beide sie nicht
gut m W die Betroffen nmlich gar kein
hilf les Jameson schribtempathie
ermöglich
EUSt vom Gegenüber wir müs aber
aufpassen dass dasuchen nicht zum
übergriffig dringe wird wi auf g sind
wir wohl in Zenig empathisch als oft len
Weg W wir WS wir müss ganz schön hinter
Frage oder wie ihr das mfit am beste ist
wieder mal der mittelwag sich off Herz
bewahre fürs Lied und der Schmerz V
anderen ohne am Elend von der Welt
zuzwifel für was wünscht i euch me
Empathie und wenn Gott Mitleid auf ner
sch sind
gespannt über Empathie und Altruismus
nachkt ist der ruter Brechmann da G's
zum Gespräch mit dem und auch zum
Gespräch über trust